foreign
good afternoon Council of Staff members
of the public welcome to this
extraordinary meeting of the Community
well-beings Committee
we have apologies from councilor kit and
councilor Stewart would let somebody
like to move that those who are accepted
Grant and Trish thank you put that all
in favor
aye against carried
uh no one on Zoom no public forum which
brings us to the item of business which
is the request to amend the Queens Park
management plan
come on welcome along
to introduce the paper for us thanks
Caroline so this um paper is
um procedural paper under the reserves
act for us to
um
go out of consultation on the footprint
for the museum to ensure that the
management plan can be amended from the
current footprint which has been
consulted on to a a larger one should
that be required
so it's a
pretty straightforward paper but would
anyone have any questions on what's been
presented to them thanks
yeah through YouTube um just wondering
about the uh part of the parcel land
that you're referring to I understood
when we uh Nigel and I talked with staff
that the existing land that the pyramid
and Observatory are on and halfway down
the tennis courts was able to be built
on and it seems by this paper that's not
the case
the tennis courts are still requiring to
be
redesignated so that that is the case so
the um if you look on what was page
three of the paper that small map there
the green area on the map is the area
that's been previously consulted on and
previously approved
and what we're looking at now is
actually extending that beyond that into
what is the yellow Square just to enable
the whole of that space so that's the
whole of the tennis court area and the
Pavilion
so the green space on your map on page
three whatever it is
um that's capable of being built on yes
it's only the yellow that was right so
it's an extension area though yeah that
was just a little bit misleading for me
because I thought we needed to do some
more work on that green space but that's
not the case no that's not okay
excellent thank you
thank you any other questions uh well if
through each year for public
consultation we'll need to make that
very clear
um because I didn't understand it either
you know I was reading it so it could be
my interpretation yeah thank you for
that feedback we'll ensure that when the
consultation documentations uh goes out
it'll be really really clear for the
public what we're looking at I think
yeah I think that might be actually a
little different to what was originally
explained to us but that was some time
ago and it may have been clarified in
the meantime sorry Tom so through your
chair
um
so I was a little confused as well
actually to be honest the way it was the
week was set out
um I might to take it that the the the
museum as we have envisaged it at the
moment at the size that we haven't
visited at the moment can actually be
built within the green area
but we'd acquire the yellow area for
expansion is that what you're saying so
the project team came to us to ask us to
Future proof that space so this is what
we're doing here is future proofing the
space to enable should it be required to
go right to the end to where the
Pavilion currently is so it's that
future proofing because obviously that
design workers I understand it hasn't
been completed as yet
right but sorry supplementary then but
um while we are waiting for the yellow
space to be reclassified
um that will not hold up the project in
any way not at all that's why we're
doing this now thank you
Mia Clark you just this is a
clarification point that when Nigel and
I spoke about
about the whole tennis court area per
half of it wasn't done it wasn't ready
to be built on and knowing that it would
take six seven eight months to do and
would need some public consultation we
thought we'd future proof by going out
to the extended area
um they could give us an option at some
later stage to consider an art gallery
there there's a combined a museum with
an art gallery attention
I'm future proofing of that so we just
we were getting hit a little bit ahead
of the able that's all done
thank you
councilor partinger thank you chair
um just a question regarding
north of the proposed space allocation
you've got Jesse called The Gardens now
a beautiful old brick wall there now
does that is that going to work is that
going to work with what's planned for
the museum obviously North facing even
though we don't we haven't seen any
designs yet
but um as we haven't seen any designs
yet yeah I'm sorry I can't no no no I'm
just wondering then my next question is
would that be a consultation thing if
something had to be altered with the
garden
um I would say we're working really
closely with the design team on this so
to ensure that there's a seamless flow
between the park and the into the museum
so I I don't foresee it being an issue
at this stage okay so say a design
needed a bit more openness towards the
roses and everything but the brick wall
you wouldn't need to consult anything
um we'd need to consult if we go outside
of the footprint that we're currently no
no
the museum wouldn't be going outside the
footprint but the brick wall may need to
be no that wouldn't be a consultation
right okay that's fine
that said
glass windows aren't great for displays
three o'clock yeah just to clarify that
point that again one of the issues that
we asked
um Lee and uh Aaron to look at was the
issue whether we could have the cafe on
the north
um cafes yeah the North West Corner
um and whether there could be some
Ambience between the Museum Cafe area
and the outside where there was a
potential maybe to have a bit of an
archway that went through to the to the
gardens which would require some sort of
I guess slight dismantling of the wall
but not the whole just to give it a
little bit of flow but again we don't
have any designs for that
Nigel thank you through you um cheer um
just by way of communication apologies
if there's a little bit of confusion
around some bits and Bobs around Museum
and the design brief there's been an
awful lot of work done as you made aware
last week and we're very much just in
the design phase
so whilst we're getting down to the
semantics today on bits and Bobs the
intention of the project team is really
clear is to make sure you are all
involved through Workshop Workshop
process
um and and we have a look at all the
details there's lots and lots of things
floating around around the museum
currently we've got it under control
we have got under control and it's not
our intention not to communicate in fact
we will communicate each and every piece
as we go forward and there's the
intention that we'll have a workshop
from last week going forward just to
bring you up to speed with some of the
things we're talking about and your
right Council of points around the juicy
called a garden and and other bits and
Bobs we've had a lot of discussion
around those things but it's just we're
in a very much an initial phase so just
to clarify today is just about footprint
and about starting a process for
corrective consultation that's it
um yeah look just following on from that
I guess I'm raising things because it's
not about the detail it's about looking
at possible things that may need
consultation
that may need consultation and if we if
you don't need to consult that so I'm
raising these things and and it's you
don't want to be six months down the
track
ah we need to consult now on something
that we forgot about that so if
everything if we're going through the
scenario of eliminating everything we
possibly need to consult on now
that that whatever options may be
available then that's good
and I can assure you we are doing that
and just to have faith give us a little
bit of time have faith which are very
very competent team that's on this
project so I have absolute faith in the
team across the board and we will get to
you and we'll workshop and we get all
the information rather than drips and
traps so just be patient we're not far
away
take it to the point Thank you which is
the amendment to the Queen's Park
management plan there are uh five
recommendations uh you have to go on the
table I'm looking for a mover
I'll move it to
councilor Scout can I just quickly check
um I'm not sure if you're on the you're
not on the committee no sorry sorry
that's right councilor sopa and Council
of bond thank you
any questions or comments before I put
the motion all in favor against Kerry
thanks Caroline no further items of
council adlow there is a one of those
recommendations
um just to note that we'll need someone
for the submissions hearing on the 14th
of March
so how many councils are you looking for
um
three councilors on a
[Music]
I was interested
happy for that
others of Interest
which is good because I think you're
going through the RMA training too
he's still looking for people who keeps
the Huntsman oh yeah
yeah I am I'm just going on the ones
that I've seen okay who's home
and Evelyn
right well it's no problem with having
more than three so that's fine
so noting that myself along with Ria
Trish Tom and Evelyn will form the
hearings panel for those submissions
so with that amendment to item four put
the motion all in favor
aye against
Karen thank you apologies for that now
that there are no further items of
General business I'll close the
extraordinary meeting and we'll take
Paul's finish the stream and I think
counts as we have a quick work